اللي ورايا ده اشهر بركان ناشط في
اندونيسيا
[موسيقى]
55 دوران في الاخر 200 سنه
عشان كده هو بركان مشهور هناك الناس بتروح
عشان تشوفه لان هو لسه بيطلع كبريت طول
الوقت وناس كتير قوي تروح تشوفه احلى لحظه
لما تنزل في المنطقه كبيره قوي كده كلها
سوداء بسبب اللافا يعني هي مش طينه هي
لعبه بتمشي فيها وبعد كده بتطلع البركان
حوالي ربع ساعه او نص ساعه هو احلى لحظه
بقى هي لما تشوف الفوهه البركان وانت على
الحرف البركان كده الصوت مهيب كده مخيف
وبعد كده طياره الدرون طبعا فخدت شنطات من
اعلى فكان شكله من فوق جميل جدا لما تطلعي
بقى من فوق الانفجار عامل ازاي كان
رهيب
[موسيقى]
هي المنطقه دي مش بيفتحوها غير لما يكونوا
متاكدين ان الموضوع امان يعني هو حصل
انفجار في 2019 اعتقد واسالوها تقريبا سنه
كامله ما حدش بيخش وحسن انفجار قريب برضو
كان قفل المنطقه بس بعد ما روحت فهي
اللحظات اللي بتبقى في النص دي لو حد عرف
يستغلها عشان يروح المميزه قوي يعني فلما
بنروح مش بيخلوا السياح يطلعوا في منطقه
غير لما الموضوع يبقوا متاكدين ان هو امام
رد فعل الناس كان متقسم ما بين ناس مرعوبه
كتير كانوا مرعوبين او خايفين وناس منبهره
من من مغامره وناس تانيه عايزه تجرب بس
انا استغربت ان في ناس كثيره كانت خايفه
اكثر من اللي هي معجبه بالموضوع يعني
[موسيقى]